F: Aujourd'hui j'engage un nouveau stagiaire
W: C'est moi !
F: Et aujourd'hui je suis avec William de la chaîne Doc Seven
W: Très bizarre ce truc de wesh wesh
F: Haha mais pourquoi ?
Pourquoi tu as fait ça?
Je sais pas ahahah
F: Déjà je te remercie publiquement de m'avoir fait passer dans un 'Salut internet'
W: Ah oui c'est vrai
F: J'avoue que ça a donné un léger coup de main
comme un espèce de... de tu sais de gros quaterback qui arrive derrière moi et qui fait pouf
Et là d'un coup tu fais pschhhhh
Pourquoi avoir choisi le 7 ?
Ha ! La question qu'on lui a jamais posé !
W: Holala, mais tu sais je vais te dire un truc. En vrai, la raison est genre super nulle, y a pas vraiment de raison
C'est juste que... 6 c'est trop peu, 8-10 c'est trop, 7 c'est joli en plus
Tu vois, les 7 péchés capitaux et y a plein de trucs avec le 7
La raison est nulle, c'est qu'il n'y a pas vraiment de raison
Mais du coup, vu que tout le monde me pose la question,
ça devient une espèce de hype et maintenant j'essaie de trouver des raisons un peu plus poussées
HAHAHAHAHA
Mais c'est ça c'est le premier des plus grands nombres premiers, les 7 nains, les 7 péchés capitaux...
Les 7 merveilles du monde euh tes 7 minutes de retard aujourd'hui
W: Tu peux faire des petits paquets, tu vois
3, 3 et 1
tu sais tu peux l'arranger de façon très belle tu vois
F: Ouais.
W: Alors que c'est pas un très beau chiffre à la base. C'est comme le 3
W : J'aime pas trop le 3
F: Donc en fait,
En fait t'aimes pas les nombres premiers même, t'aimes pas le 3, t'aimes pas le 7
Il faut savoir que quand il est arrivé ici, j'ai reçu les meubles aujourd'hui, ils étaient pas montés et il a tenu absolument à les monter.
*rires*
W: T'imagines
F: Par contre c'est vrai que j'ai monté cette chaise là devant toi pour que tu puisses t'asseoir.
W: C'est vrai. T'as vu, ils ont l'impression qu'il y a plein de trucs et tout alors qu'en fait si on montre l'autre côté, il n'y a rien pour l'instant
F: Ah mais oui tellement
Ça c'est un, on a mis un William ici.
Ça c'est les déchets
Ça c'est les meubles pas encore montés
Ça c'est toute cette partie fort bien décorée ma foi hein !
Quand on s'est vu l'autre soir à l'apéroTube
W: Oui
F: Tu m'as dit quand..
W: Tu étais bourré
F: Oui c'est vrai un peu oui
*Rires de William*
F: Et à cette soirée là, tu m'as dit "Put*** c'est quand que tu me fais un truc de mentaliste?"
donc on s'en est fait un petit à l'arrache là bas
Aujourd'hui on va en faire un plus sérieux, plus costaud
*Générique*
F: J'ai préparé ce qu'on appelle une petite prédiction
toi, tu sais pas forcément ce que c'est.
Vous, vous savez ce que c'est une prédiction.
C'est un papier où j'ai écris quelques choses dedans
W: Non c'est une corbeille ça
F: Alors elle est ici
W: Ah d’accord
F: Entre l'aimant et la corbeille comme ça avec l'aimant on est sûr qu'il y aura pas de change possible. Tu vois?
Je ne peux pas le subtiliser pour le changer contre un autre
F: J'ai prévu quelques petites... choses
W: J'avais pas vu tout ça que t'as caché là.
F: Ben ouais, en fait, je me suis dit "7 à quoi ça me fait penser?"
Ça m'a fait penser à VIBUJOR, moi dans ma tête, 7
W: Ah quoi?
F: VIBUJOR c'est un moyen mnémotechnique que j'ai pour retenir les 7 couleurs de l'arc en ciel dans l'ordre.
donc Violet, Indigo, Bleu, le U pour vert,
parce que je pouvais pas remettre un autre V, le J pour jaune, O de orange, et R de rouge
W : D'accord !
W: Tu es un peu spé toi comme gars non?
F: Ouais. Quand je cherchais un truc sur 7, je me suis dit
"Ah ben ouais  Doc Seven le 7, les 7 couleurs de l'arc en ciel. Je vais faire un truc avec des couleurs."
Et tu constateras que j'en ai pris?
W: 5
F: 5, est ce que tu te doutes de pourquoi?
W: Parce qu'on peut faire des mix avec le violet et tout?
F: Non, c'est juste parce que dans Seven, il y a que 5 lettres
W: Ah !
F: Et j'y viens, tu vas colorier les lettres... de Doc Seven
W: D'accord *rire*
F: Juste de Seven
W: Ouais
F: Et là tu t'aperçois que j'ai arrêté de dessiner au CM1 à peu près
W: *rires* ah ouais c'est très bon, parce que moi je savais pas tout ça là.
F: Et non !
W: Tu es en train de tout me montrer là.
F: Doc Seven, et ça c'est censé être un V, tu vois.
W: D'accord.
F: Voilà S, premier E, V, deuxième E et N.
Alors, je te dis je vais essayer de t'influencer sur des choses.
W: D'accord
F: Donc on va faire ça plutôt lentement.
Je te donnerai des choses à faire,
je te parlerai au fur et à mesure,
mais ne va jamais plus vite que moi.
W: OK
F: Et, ne me contredis pas.
W: D'accord
F: C'est-à-dire une fois que tu as choisi une couleur, tu as choisi une couleur
F: Tu n'en changes plus
W: OK
F: OK
W: Très bien
F: Tu as du vert, du jaune, du bleu, du rouge et du orange.
W: Est ce que tu sais là, mes 2... là il y en a 2 que j'adore.
F: Ben il y a  le bleu, parce que tu l'as regardé direct mais...
W: Ouais
F: L'autre *hésite* c'était parti par là, c'est le jaune, le jaune?
W: Non
F: Ah c'est quoi avec le bleu?
W: C'est le orange.
D'ailleurs tu remarqueras que,
il y a beaucoup de mes titres dans mes vidéos qui sont Orange
F: Dans les Putaclics.
W: Non, *Rires de Fabien* pas dans les titres eux même
mais quand dans les vidéos, je mets des titres, des dates, des machins
c'est souvent en orange et en vert
F: Je croyais que c'était par rapport à l'aspect marketing,
qui est très efficace, en fait,
le Orange quand on veut faire passer une info est très très efficace.
W : C'est juste parce que j'aime bien le Orange
F : Je dirais bleu et orange et comme je peux remonter la vidéo
W: C'est ça
*rires*
F: Je vais me tourner,
je vais regarder là,
il y a pas de miroir? Il y a rien? on est d'accord?
Je vais me retourner
et tu es un peu le garant vis à vis de ta communauté
et de la mienne que je ne peux rien voir. D'accord?
W: Ouais. Il y a des trucs dans les pages d'après ou pas?
F: Non il y a rien du tout
Tu peux feuilleter.
W: Déjà tu peux rien voir.
F: Tu peux me faire des dédicaces.
W: Mais attends, toi tu vas voir lesquels ils manquent
F: Non je ne vais jamais me retourner
W: Ah tu vas jamais te retourner. D'accord
F: Tu vas vite comprendre
Je mets ça, je mets ça comme ça aussi
*Rire de William*
F: Là, tu es sûr que je vois rien.
W: Oui
F: Alors, à partir de ce moment là de la vidéo je ne ferais plus de coupe. Je te le dis
W: D'accord
F: Fait très attention à tout ce que tu dis
Parce que si je fais des coupes on peut penser que... il y a un arrangement etc...
W: Non mais il y a pas de problème, tu peux ne pas faire de coupe.
F: Euh... tu as 5 feutres dans le pot. Toujours.
W: Oui
F: Tu prends un des 5 feutres dans tes mains, spontanément, le 1er qui vient ou celui qui te faire plaisir.
W: OK
F: Voilà tu en prends un des 5 dans tes mains
W: Très bien
Je l'ai
F: Tu me dis quand c'est bon
W: C'est bon
F: C'est bon. OK tu le débouches et tu vas faire le N la dernière lettre avec
W: Le N?
F: Oui
W: Je le colorie en entier?
F: Ouais. En fait, faut bien qu'on voie la couleur que tu as utilisé quoi
W: D'accord
Attends je leur montre à l'écran
T'as pas écouté le son que faisait chaque feutre quand tu colories avec, j'espère
F: Non
W: Pour reconnaître le son des couleurs
F: Non, je ne suis pas psychopathe à ce point
De toute manière, je t'ai dit... donner la lettre à colorier avant même que tu l'ouvres ou que tu colories
W: C'est vrai
F: Une fois que c'est fini...
W: C'est le V tu m'as dit qu'on colorie? *petit rire*
F: Le N. *rire* Mais je sais que tu fais exprès.
Quand c'est fait tu le rebouches et tu le mets plus loin sur la table.
Pour l'isoler, je ne veux plus...
si possible qu'il ne soit plus dans ton champs de vision à toi.
W: Ah... euh...
F: Même par terre si tu veux.
W: Vas y par terre
F: OK donc il ne te reste plus que 4 feutres dans le pot.
W: Ouais
F: euh... tu vas...
W: C'est très excitant comme jeu
F: Tu vas s'il te plait penser à un bon souvenir
W: Un bon souvenir? *réfléchi*
F: Dans ta tête
W: Ouais
F: Maintenant que c'est fait.
Tu regardes le pot.
W: Mouais
F: Et dans ta tête, sans le prendre, dans ta tête,
tu choisis l'un des 4 feutres
c'est celui que tu vas prendre mais ne le prends pas pour l'instant
W: OK
F: C'est bon?
W: Ouais
F: Donc là, le 1er coup je t'ai un peu speedé à choisir une couleur,
là je t'ai vraiment fait prendre le temps avec une émotion plutôt positive.
W: Hm hm
F: Tu prends le feutre que tu as décidé dans tes mains parmi les 4 feutres.
Tu leur feras voir si tu veux.
W: Je le prends là?
F: Ouais ouais vas y prends le
En fait, l'important c'était que tu fasses toi le choix à l'avance et tu colories le 1er E avec
W: D'accord
F: La deuxième lettre
W: Très bien
Je colorie vite fait
*Accéléré*
F: Une fois fini tu le rebouches et tu le mets par terre
Et maintenant, dès que je claque des doigts tu prends un feutre dans tes mains.
Maintenant [Claque des doigts]
W: OK
F: C'est bon?
W: Oui
F: Tu le débouches et tu fait la 3ème lettre c'est à dire le V.
Tu viens de faire le 1er E, tu fais le V
W: Mais là, je suis en stress de ouf que t'y arrives
*rires*
F: Non tu pourras jamais être aussi stressé que moi
*Rires de William*
W: Je le rebouche?
F: Tu le rebouche, tu le sors de ton champs de vision et ...
W: Par terre
F: Ouais
Il te reste 2 feutres regarde les. Prends le temps de les regarder
Tu prends bien le temps de les regarder
Tu décides dans ta tête de celui que tu prendrais.
W: Ouais
F: Et je vais te demander de prendre l'autre, celui que tu n'as pas décidé de prendre
W: D'accord
F: OK, donc tu le prends dans tes mains, tu le débouches et tu fais le 2ème E
Et après tu prends le dernier pour faire le S
W: Je le fais dans la foulée?
F: Ouais
W: On s'en fiche je ne peux pas changer d'avis
F: Exactement. Et moi je peux même commencer à sortir de mon...
W: Non mais attends je ne veux pas que tu regardes !
F: Ben maintenant ça changera plus rien
W: Attends je veux leur montrer d'abord
F: Ma seule angoisse c'est que tu aies fait le S en orange c'est tout.
W: Pourquoi?
F: Parce que ça... ça m'emmerderais mais..
W: C'est vrai. Ah merde
*Rires de Fabien*
F: OK c'était ma seule angoisse quoi.
Put**n c'est très bien fait
W: C'est joli hein?
F: Donc tu as commencé par prendre du jaune
W: Ouais
F: Après tu as pris le rouge
F: Après tu as pris le bleu,
W: Le vert
F:  le orange, le vert put**n
W: Ouais
F: Le bleu
F: Et enfin le Orange
W: C'est ça
F: OK
Ça te plait en tout cas comme résultat?
W: Ah oui je trouve ça joli moi
F: Je fais bien voir
Tu te souviens qu'il y a une prédiction?
W: Oui
F: *Soupire* Ben je te laisse la prendre et puis après
W: Non mais vas y je sais que tu m'as n*qué de toute façon. Je le sens.
F: On en parle après
W: Je le sens sinon tu aurais pas dit. Tu aurais pas dit ta petite phrase sur le orange
F: Tu décapsules
W: Je la montre ou...?
Ah non c'est un dessin que tu as fait
F: Ouais tu peux le regarder. Et puis après tu pourras leur faire voir si tu veux
W: Oh le bat**d *rires*
F: OUUUIIII
W: Mais c'est pas possible
F: S orange, le rouge du E, le vert du V, le bleu et le jaune
Ça fait plaisir.
W: Ah mais tu es un gros dingue.
Non mais tu expliques ensuite le raisonnement ou pas ou c'est dans une autre vidéo?
F: Non non mais c'est vrai que dans la plupart de mes vidéos j'explique ce que je fais et quand je le fais
Et de temps en temps, régulièrement sur la chaîne, je fais des trucs un peu ouf comme ça
et je leur dis la phrase suivante, que je vais vous redire
Ne cherchez pas d'explication,
et inutile de me la demander,
ça fait partie de ce petit côté que je garde...
pour moi
déjà d'une part pour vous bluffer dans les vidéos
et pour continuer à vous bluffer et vous faire marrer en spectacle
Ça t'as plu?
W: C'est lourd. Put**n c'est fou.
F: Tiens je te laisse tout
W: Non mais c'est fou
J'ai commencé par le rouge?
F: Tu as commencé par... Non non non...
W:  Non j'ai commencé par le jaune
F: Toi tu as... on commence par le... enfin je voulais que tu commences par le N.
W: Mais tu vois... mais c'est ça, mais juste le fait de "Vas y prend le 1er" comme ça.
C'est tout
Mais c'est ouf, OK très bien. Je ne vais pas chercher pourquoi.
F: Merci beaucoup d'avoir participé à cette expérience du Mental Vlog.
W: C'est très bluffant
F: Abonnez vous à la chaîne de Doc Seven.
Si jamais vous ne le connaissez pas, ce qui serait étonnant pour 70% de ma communauté.
*Rires*
Je vous recommande vivement de regarder la chaîne
et regardez la vidéo que je vous mets dans la description
c'est la vidéo que j'ai faite sur ton livre
et je vous explique un peu ce qu'il y a dans le bouquin
et je vous donne mon avis sincère dessus, ce que j'aime et ce que j'aime pas.
Et donc n'hésitez pas à le regarder
Ah si, j'ai dit un truc que j'aimais pas dans ton livre
W: En même temps, je t'ai payé 2000 balles, donc encore heureux
F: Put**n 2000 ça a changé [les multi-com]
*rires*
F: La préface pour moi elle était un peu courte,
j'aurai bien aimé lire un petit historique ou pourquoi tu as lancé ces vidéos etc...
comment je fais mes recherches un peu au quotidien ou j'en sais rien, tu vois?
W: D'accord. Pas con
F: Tu vois, comment je vais sur Wikipedia
W: Pour le prochain *rires*
Comment je vais sur Wikipedia, oh le bat**d
F: Mais c'est la seule.
Et j'ai toujours pas compris pourquoi tu as appelé ça "Les questions cons"
Mais...
*Rire de William"
F: Merci mec d'être venu jusqu'à la maison pour ça,
d'avoir traversé Paris depuis le 4 rue des Eglantines
dans le 1er arrondissement
*rires de William*
W: Non mais arrête la personne qui habite là bas, ça se trouve, imagine elle a le même nom de famille que moi.
F: Merci beaucoup d'avoir regardé cette vidéo ça c'est très cool.
N'oubliez pas de vous abonner avant de partir si ce n'est pas déjà fait
Puisque le Mental Vlog c'est une vidéo par jour pendant 1 an.
Du 1er janvier au 31 décembre donc rendez-vous demain
A 17h
Ciao !
W: Il parle vite
W: Ça j'ai jamais compris à quoi ça servait
F: Put**n je me suis jamais posé la question.
W: A part l'accrocher.
Ah mais je crois, c'est ça tu sais tu as des verrous
F: Ah pour les antivols
W: Tu peux mettre des antivols là dedans. Tu le mets et ça ouvre 2 branches un truc comme ça
F: Est ce que tu peux faire un top 7 des meilleurs antivols?
*rires*
Les antivols les plus badass de l'histoire
W: Si tu savais le nombre d'idée à la con qu'on me propose tout le temps
Genre: les lampadaires, le top 7 des lampes, des plus beaux lampadaires à Paris.